[Musica]
quante volte ci siamo detti non ce la
farò mai non riuscirò mai ad arrivare a
quell'obiettivo senza una
raccomandazione o questa cosa non fa per
me
questo me lo ripetevo anch'io sì
quando ho scoperto atletica avevo 10
anni vivevo in un paese in provincia di
bari palo del colle dove non avevamo una
struttura adatta per l'atletica leggera
ma solo asfalto
allenavamo su una lingua d'asfalto di un
chilometro accanto una ferrovia o alle
volte anche in una scuola superiore
nella palestra scoperta che potete
vedere qui
qui mi sono avvicinato l'atletica perché
amo le sfide le ama voliamo ancora
mi faceva arrivare primi
anche se alle volte un po mi dispiace va
a battere i miei compagni d'allenamento
così qui ho incontrato il mio primo
allenatore giovane zaccheo che ha visto
in me subito delle potenzialità sapeva
farci divertire
nell'allenamento e quindi mi ha aiutato
mi ha assecondato a scegliere la
disciplina che oggi pratico che la
marcia perché mi piace la marcia perché
è una fusione tra fatica che occorre per
fare tanti chilometri ma anche tecnica
perché la marcia si basa appunto su due
fondamentali regole
una è la sospensione e quindi non
bisogna mai lasciare il contatto col
terreno almeno con un piede ed altri
invece è il bloccaggio che sia al
momento in cui il tallone tocca il suolo
e ginocchio deve essere completamente
teso a tre errori quindi ammonizioni si
va in pit lane per due minuti alla
quarta se vuoi al contrario di quello
che state pensando io non ho iniziato
subito a vincere anzi in una delle mie
primissime gare importanti
sono stato colpito da una squalifica
questo per me in età giovanile era un
peso grandissimo enorme non riuscivo a
sostenerlo e quindi nella mia mente c'è
stato subito un dubbio ma la marcia fa
davvero per me
questo mi ha portato a smettere con la
marcia la mia fortuna è stata proprio il
mio allenatore giovanni che all'inizio
mia seconda va
così a sorpresa mi diceva ma ti va di
fare una gara di marcia la mia risposta
inizialmente erano lui sapeva che
forzando mi io mi sarei allontanato
quindi ogni tanto così questa domanda me
la ripropone ma anche un giorno la mia
risposta diventassi e credetemi ad oggi
non ho ancora capito quale strategia
adottata in allenatore per riportarli
sulla retta via qui ho deciso
che ho deciso di fissare il mio man gol
qual è il mio mengon le olimpiadi
ho iniziato a vincere delle gare a
livello regionale italiani a
qualificarmi anche ad eventi
internazionali giovanili fino a che ho
deciso di alzare l'asticella ho cambiato
città e allenatore mi sono trasferito a
sesto san giovanni da alessandro
gandellini ha iniziato ad avere dei
buoni risultati fino anche a
qualificarmi al primo europeo dei grandi
ma qui un'altra delusione taglio il
traguardo terzultimo
rifletto cosa non ha funzionato e ho
capito da questa gara che non importa i
tempi che è fatto nelle gare precedenti
ma devi capire quale strategia adottare
nel momento giusto
in determinate gare
così il mio obiettivo essendo le
olimpiadi a rio si avvicinava nel 2016
arrivano infortunio
microfrattura da stress alla tibia
destra questo mi preoccupa perché
nell'anno precedente aveva avuto lo
stesso infortunio ma a sinistra qui
capisco quanto per me ha valore la
marcia ma marcia per me è vita è una
passione e senza di lei non vivrei come
se fosse ossigeno per me quindi decido
di andare avanti di non fermarmi lì e di
alzare ancora l'asticella che faccio
cambia ancora allenatore è città vada ad
ostia sotto la guida di patrick farci
sepe che tuttora il mio allenatore
con lui nel 2017
decidiamo di eliminare uno dei miei
piccoli limiti mentali che è il
cronometro abbiamo iniziato a gareggiare
senza perché spesso guardando il
cronometro vedevo sempre dei tempi più
lenti di quelli che mi aspettavo e
questo mi demoralizza va così
gareggiando senza ho iniziato ad avere
ottimi risultati fino a che a giugno
2000 19 e premetto io ero convinto di
non poter fare sotto loro e 20
giugno 2019 boh
record italiano un'ora 17 e 45 sono
incredulo stracontento ma le delusioni
sono sempre dietro l'angolo
arriva quindi i mondiali di doha 2019
pit lane due minuti da giocarmi una
medaglia arrivo xiv
ok al momento sono dispiaciuto ma la mia
vittoria nelle sconfitte e capire dove
si è sbagliato per non rifare gli stessi
errori
in un'intervista dico tra le altre cose
ok adesso che province gli olimpieri
così continuo ad allenarmi sempre con il
mio obiettivo ben in mente
e arriva l'inverno 2020 21 dove per noi
la preparazione invernale è davvero
fondamentale
che un altro infortunio non te lo fai
quattro mesi lontano dalla marcia che
faccio non sto fermo
trovo un metodo alternativo piscina
cardio fitness con frequenze altissime
montand bike e tutto ciò che potevo fare
in palestra che non mi creasse problemi
così ho continuato ho ripreso a marciare
fino a che a un mese e mezzo dalle
olimpiadi
ancora un infortunio ma un entità minore
riesco a marciare ma non a svolgere
l'allenamento previsto con il mio
allenatore
quindi qui decido di affidarmi
ciecamente del mio allenatore del mio
fisioterapista
ma voglio fare qualcosa anch'io mi dico
se a livello fisico non posso essere al
cento per cento alle mie olimpiadi devo
compensare a livello mentale
inizio a ripetermi due frasi
farò di tutto per vincere le olimpiadi
sono il più forte del mondo
questo
questa seconda frase non è un fondo
statistico perché non ero il più forte
del mondo ma in una strategia di
autoconvincimento e così fino a tokyo ho
continuato a ripetermi queste due fasi
ogni giorno arrivò a tokyo
io sono tranquillo sono rilassato sono
sicura di me negli occhi dei miei
avversari
leggo l'ansia che sono tranquillo così
siamo sulla partenza sulla linea di
partenza
boom sparo si parte le mie sensazioni
non sono ottimali che faccio mi ripeto
poi ma è bene stare rilassato stai
tranquillo se il più forte del mondo e
quindi continuo così fino al 17 esimo
chilometro
qui è un momento clou della gara dove i
due giapponesi
decidono di sferrare un attacco un
cambio di ritmo devastante in quel
momento è come se io vedessi al rallenty
li vede allontanarsi pian piano io
mentalmente anche un po da presuntuoso
faccio ma dove volete andare io sono il
più forte così cambio ritmo lì a fianco
e poi metto davanti in totale sofferenza
ora starete pensando vabbè poi vinci no
non ancora perché a un chilometro e
mezzo dall'arrivo ovviamente mi fa uno
scherzetto
inizio pensare tra la fatica il fiato
sul collo del giapponese i giri infiniti
max anche nell'argento olimpico comunque
non è male
ma questo pensiero nella mia mente resta
solo per un secondo perché poi ripenso a
mia figlia a mia moglie e tutte le
scelte che ho fatto per essere lì in
quel momento in quel posto preciso
quindi
riprendo lucidità e dico no io sono qui
solo per vincere non voglio nient'altro
non posso accontentarmi perché
probabilmente non mi ricapiterà più
un'occasione del genere quindi mi metto
davanti cambio ritmo in totale di
sofferenza stoli soli e martello fino a
che
arriva il momento finale ultimi metri
vedo davanti a me aprirsi lo striscione
con scritto tokyo 20 20
capisco che quello striscione sta
aspettando solo me in quel momento sono
incredulo nella mia mente mi passa tu mi
scorre tutta la mia carriera da quando
sono partito a 10 anni fino a quel
momento
sono lì mi avvicina sempre più a questo
striscione
fino a che il mio ventre tocca questo
striscione e allora dico ho vinto le
olimpiadi
io
il sogno di un bambino è diventato
realtà
mi fermo a pensare da dove sono partito
dall aver timore dispiacere nel battere
i miei compagni d'allenamento a
diventare il campione olimpico che sono
oggi ho capito due cose 1 che sono
diventate un atleta egoista nel senso
che quello che voglio me lo vado a
prendere a tutti i costi e 2 che tutti
gli ostacoli che si frappongono fra noi
è il nostro obiettivo sono lì perché ci
vogliono insegnare qualcosa noi siamo
liberi se superarli e accettare l'i
nsegnamento oppure stare lì a guardare
gli altri che vanno avanti
quindi quello che io penso degli
ostacoli e che siano quel surplus che
rende la nostra vita
una fantastica avventura
raccontata la mia storia mi voglio
lasciare con una domanda con un quesito
chi può dire
se una cosa è possibile o impossibile
se non si fa di tutto per raggiungerla
grazie